[Música]
20 de octubre de 2011 el dirigente libio
muamar el gadafi es capturado y
asesinado y amigos ya os digo que no fue
ejecutado precisamente de una forma muy
civilizada si se lo merecía o no eso ya
os lo dejo a vosotros El caso es que la
muerte de gaddafi supuso El fin a casi
42 años de ferre gobierno en 2011 Libia
cambió probablemente para siempre El
problema es que ese cambio no dejó una
situación precisamente a la gueña y
desde entonces para colmo todo ha ido de
mal en peor según la ONU el riesgo para
la estabilidad de Libia Se incrementa
tras los mortíferos enfrentamientos
entre milicias y la agitación en Niger y
Sudán los supervivientes de las
inundaciones de Libia se enfrentan al
trauma al menos 4000 personas habrían
muerto cuando la tormenta azotó derna
tras la inundación de Libia las armas
sin detonar suponen un nuevo riesgo
durante la primera semana de septiembre
la tormenta Daniel pasó por el
Mediterráneo y provocó unas inundaciones
inmensas en liia las víctimas mortales
se contaron por miles Claro que esta es
tan solo la última de las catástrofes y
calamidades que están sufriendo los
libios en los últimos años la caída del
régimen de gaddafi provocó una segunda
guerra civil y un enorme caos Pero qué
pasó exactamente tras la caída de
gaddafi por qu Libia acabó su vida en el
caos más profundo podrá este país
recuperarse en los próximos años pues
gasolina y arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
queridos amigos y amigas A veces la
historia puede ser mucho más repetitiva
de lo que nos podemos llegar a imaginar
Y para muestra un botón el 4 de mayo de
1980 Tito el líder indiscutido de la
otra hora gran yugoslavia pasó a mejor
vida con su muerte se desencadenaron un
montón de tensiones étnicas y políticas
en los balcanes que terminaron como
todos albis como el rosario de la Aurora
la desaparición de Tito trajo consigo la
desintegración de yugoslavia y un montón
de conflictos y sangrientas guerras pero
un momento no se supone que Este era un
vídeo sobre Libia Pues sí lo es así que
tranquilos que no se nos ha ido la
cabeza El caso es que el derrocamiento y
el asesinato de gaddafi A muy señor de
la Libia contemporánea dio un paso a un
escenario muy pero que muy similar Y es
que veréis Libia es un país complejo
está compuesto socialmente por múltiples
facciones de distintas tribus y etnias
hablamos en concreto de más de 30 tribus
y clanes familiares que históricamente
han tenido mucho peso en la política de
este país y claro durante las últimas
cinco décadas lo que todos estos grupos
tuvieron en común fue por un lado el
sistema de mano dura que regía en el
país y por otro el enorme aparato de
favores privilegios y populismo
petrolero que dirigía gaddafi ya sabéis
la política del palo y la
zanahoria pero cuando gadafi cayó toda
esa especie de estabilidad y armonía
pagada con el dinero del Oro negro con
burbujas desapareció no se produjo ning
ninguna transición sino que el país se
sumió en el más completo caos y eso
puede explicarse por esto las tribus y
sectas que componen estos estados de
carácter artificial se han mantenido
unidas durante mucho tiempo gracias al
puño de hierro de las potencias
coloniales Los Reyes o los dictadores
militares estos estados no tienen
verdaderos ciudadanos en el sentido
moderno las rotaciones democráticas en
el poder son imposibles porque cada
tribu vive bajo el lema gobernar o Morir
o mi tribu o secta está en el poder o
estamos Muertos pero qué ocurrió
exactamente tras la caída del régimen
del Gran líder del socialismo árabe pues
amigos amigas ahora mismo lo vamos a
ver del despegue exitoso al aterrizaje
forzoso en el año 2011 estalló en tunez
la conocida como Primavera árabe un
proceso de protesta política que
rápidamente se extendió por todo el
norte de África y partes de oriente
medio y Libia no fue una excepción de
repente se desataron grandes
manifestaciones y protestas contra el
gobierno un movimiento que terminó
convertido en una auténtica Guerra Civil
el 26 de febrero de ese año 2011 el
consejo de seguridad de las Naciones
Unidas aprobó congelar los bienes a los
jerarcas del gobierno libio y también
declaró un embargo de armas sobre este
país más tarde el 17 de marzo se aprobó
también el establecimiento de una zona
de exclusión aérea de vuelos para
proteger supuestamente a los civiles de
las zonas Rebeldes de los ataques aéreos
que pudiera llevar a cabo el ejército
libio estas dos resoluciones fueron
impulsadas por Francia y Reino Unido
pero ni Rusia ni China vetaron la
iniciativa es decir que todo el mundo se
volvió de repente contra gaddafi y de
hecho Poco después la propia otan
intervino en este conflicto para
aniquilar las capacidades militares del
régimen de tripoli al final Como ya os
hemos contado el régimen cayó y en
octubre de ese mismo año el propio gadfi
terminó siendo capturado torturado y
ejecutado Libia amigos pasó a estar
dirigida por el llamado consejo nacional
de transición este órgano tuvo el
control durante 10 meses y su misión era
bastante Clara estabilizar el país y
organizar unas elecciones es que abrirán
paso a una nueva etapa democrática Libia
es un estado democrático independiente
en el que el pueblo es la fuente de los
poderes la ciudad de trípoli será la
capital del Estado el islam es la
religión del estado y la principal
fuente de legislación es la
jurisprudencia islámica el estado
garantizará a los no musulmanes la
libertad de practicar ritos religiosos
el árabe es su lengua oficial El estado
garantizará los derechos culturales de
todos los componentes de la sociedad
Libia y sus lenguas se considerarán
nacionales Pues bien el consejo cumplió
y en julio del 2012 se celebraron
elecciones para escoger el Congreso
Nacional el cual luego tendría la misión
de elegir a un Primer Ministro y poner
en marcha un proceso Constituyente en
esas elecciones participaron más del 60
por de los libios con derecho a voto Así
que en aquel momento todo pintaba
razonablemente bien el panorama era
prometedor sí había mucha tensión pero
en menos de un año el país había sido
capaz de organizar unas elecciones
nacionales y formar un gobierno sin
embargo amigos Lo cierto es que el
optimismo duró tanto como un helado en
el desierto nunca Mejor
[Música]
dicho en las elecciones parlamentarias
de Libia en 2012 se utilizó un sistema
conocido como el voto único no
transferible esto quiere decir que los
votantes Tenían un solo voto que podían
emitir por un candidato individual en
sus distritos Eso es todo nada de
candidatos nacionales lo que provocó una
elección masiva de perfiles
independientes El problema es que esto
fraccion al congreso en múltiples
monobloques limitando la posibilidad de
crear y sostener mayorías estables para
colmo comenzaron a proliferar todo tipo
de facciones islamistas radicales como
el Isis que vieron la oportunidad de
aprovechar el desgobierno para ganar
territorio pese a todo en 2014 se
celebraron nuevas elecciones pero en
aquellos comicios la participación ya
fue solo del 18 por. y Poco después todo
se rompió una facción de los antiguos
miembros del Congreso Nacional se negó a
reconocer los resultados y estableció Un
gobierno paralelo en trípoli fue el
llamado gobierno de la salvación
nacional al mismo tiempo el congreso
recién elegido formó su propio gobierno
en tobruk una ciudad Libia que es
fronteriza con
Egipto por supuesto la existencia de dos
gobiernos paralelos fue la gota que
colmó el vaso la división se extendió a
las fuerzas armadas y el país acabó
sumergido en una segunda guerra civil y
claro si a la lucha interna le sumamos
el auge del estado islámico la formación
de milicias locales autónomas como los
tuar H stow Boy y la proliferación de
intereses sirios rusos egipcios y turcos
Lo cierto es que Libia acabó convertida
en una especie de todos contra todos
para el año 2015 tal y como podéis ver
el mapa de este país era el tablero de
uno de esos puzzles que nadie sabe como
demonios montar un puzzle compuesto por
diferentes gobiernos tribus y grupos
yihadistas en resumen que la existencia
de una Libia unida parecía cosa del
pasado y por supuesto todos estos
enfrentamientos tuvieron también
consecuencias para el mayor negocio de
este país el oro negro con
burbujas
porque amigos amigas Libia tiene una de
las 10 mayores reservas de petróleo
convencional de todo el mundo y hasta
que estalló la primavera árabe su nivel
de producción estaba creciendo
progresivamente Sin embargo a partir de
entonces Todo cambió como veis la
producción se hundió un 75 por en 2014
2015 y 2016 y aunque luego se ha
recuperado sigue un 30% por debajo de
sus niveles del año 2010 tenía más fe en
que los europeos dada la proximidad de
Libia se implicaran en el proceso de
transición el grado de división tribal
en Libia era mayor de lo que esperaban
nuestros analistas y nuestra capacidad
para tener allí cualquier tipo de
estructura con la que pudiéramos
interactuar y empezar a formar y a
proporcionar recursos se vino abajo muy
rápidamente en cualquier caso en
diciembre del 2015 se firmó el acuerdo
político libio un acuerdo promovido por
el consejo de seguridad de Naciones
Unidas que estableció una mesa de
diálogo entre las diferentes facciones
políticas del país esto sirvió para
poner en marcha un nuevo proceso de paz
y finalmente en 2020 la mayor parte de
bandos enfrentados logró acordar un alto
el fuego y establecer una agenda
electoral única el nuevo gobierno Está
compuesto por un consejo presidencial
que hasta la fecha está conducido por
Mohamed memphi y un Primer Ministro
Abdul hamid bé ambos están en funciones
desde febrero y marzo de 2021
respectivamente y hace ya bastante de
eso su misión era preparar el terreno
para organizar nuevas elecciones algo
que no han hecho y la pregunta es por
qué no se han celebrado elecciones En
qué situación se encuentra Olivia quién
maneja el cotarro pues mucho ojo porque
puede que el futuro no sea tan diferente
al pasado
atentos un nuevo
Caudillo amigos la Segunda Guerra Civil
produjo un sinfín de líderes donde
destacan varios civiles como aref Ali
nayet exembajador libio ante emiratos
árabes Unidos o el mismísimo Abdul hamid
bebé el actual Primer Ministro sin
embargo los pesos pesados del momento
siguen concentrados en nombres que nos
remiten al pasado y no al futuro futuro
por ejemplo podemos encontrar a nada más
y nada menos que a saif al islam gaddafi
o suena el apellido Exacto es el mismo
que el del anterior dictador porque
estamos hablando de su primogénito de
hecho este tipo anunció en noviembre de
2021 su pretensión de participar en los
comicios presidenciales lo cual en
cierto modo es una novedad porque el
primogénito del dictador livio ha sido
desde el derrocamiento de su padre una
especie de ficha de puzle las
negociaciones entre las distintas
facciones que se disputan el control del
país saif al islam gadfi quedó en manos
de la milicia de zintan que operaba en
el noroeste de Libia y que de alguna
manera no tenía un bando fijo en la
Segunda Guerra Civil en cualquier caso
la cámara de representantes de Libia
consideró otorgarle una amnistía como
parte del proceso de pacificación pero
el resto de los actores políticos libios
rechazaron esa opción sin embargo
finalmente en 2017 fue liberado Y desde
entonces su paradero es un Enigma
apareció en 2021 en una ciudad del sur
de Libia para anunciar su candidatura a
la presidencia Pese a que sobre él pesa
una pena de muerte impuesta por
tribunales de trípoli y una orden de
captura emitida por la mismísima Corte
Penal Internacional Pero así es la Libia
actual luego en el Polo puesto tenemos a
jalifa belcin hafter alfer hanani un
viejo conocido de la política
[Música]
Libia Coronel del ejército fue
encarcelado y enviado al exilio por el
mismísimo gadfi después de tener un mal
resultado contra iones Rebelde chadian
durante un conflicto en la frontera en
los años 80 Claro que en 2011 hafter vio
su oportunidad y regresó al país como un
flamante señor de la guerra en 2014
cuando estalló la Segunda Guerra Civil
condujo al ejército nacional libio bajo
la autoridad de la cámara de
representante electa y no reconocida por
el gobierno de tripoli hafter queridos
amigos es un declarado crítico contra el
actual gobierno del acuerdo nacional
jalifa haftar el señor de la guerra
libio no está interesado en llegar a un
compromiso famosamente cascarrabias el
señor de la guerra de 76 años no parece
interesado en llegar a un acuerdo lanzó
una ofensiva para capturar tripoli en
abril horas después de que el secretario
general de la ONU Antonio guterrez
aterrizara en la capital para preparar
una conferencia de paz las tropas de
hafter pasaron olímpicamente del proceso
de paz hasta que se vieron obligadas a
bajar las armas tras el alto el fuego
Nacional de 2020 pero pese a ello no
parece particularmente comprometido con
ninguna transición democrática y muchos
le ven como uno de los grandes
obstáculos en ese camino de todas formas
no todas son malas noticias desde marzo
de este 2023 opera un mecanismo
denominado 6 + 6 donde seis miembros de
la cámara de representantes Libia y seis
miembros del alto consejo del Estado del
gobierno negocian las bases y las
condiciones para poder celebrar de una
vez por todas elecciones en esas
elecciones la postulación de saif al
islam gadfi está de momento anulada Ya
que en el proceso electoral no podrán
participar sujetos condenados por la
justicia y por otra parte el propio
haftar pesa todo parece estar dando su
brazo a torcer el enviado de la ONU y
haftar coinciden en la necesidad de
finalizar el proyecto de ley electoral
me he reunido hoy en bengasi con el
Mariscal de campo jalifa haftar hemos
acordado la necesidad de finalizar el
proyecto de ley electoral del comité 6+
6 y crear las condiciones propicias para
unas elecciones nacionales inclusivas en
Libia y amigos así estaban las cosas
Hasta que llegó un nuevo desastre que lo
ha vuelto a cambiar todo por
completo sacando
[Música]
tajada durante las primeras sem de
septiembre de 2023 la tormenta Daniel
provocó Auténticos diluvios en los
países mediterráneos en Libia este
fenómeno provocó el colapso de presas y
el desborde de torrentes para que os
hagáis una idea en localidades como
albaida al noroeste del país en 24 horas
cayó el equivalente a 18 meses de
precipitaciones habituales es decir que
en unas horas cayó la misma cantidad de
agua que suele caer en un año y medio de
locos las inundaciones dejaron tras de
sí miles y miles de muertos y
desaparecidos y decenas de miles de
damnificados en un país que no parece
salir de una para meterse en otra peor
Claro que donde muchos vieron una
tragedia otros encontraron una
oportunidad xalifa haftar aprovechó la
ocasión para perfilarse como el gestor
del rescate del pueblo jalifa haftar
utilizará las inundaciones de Libia para
profundizar su control el hombre fuerte
del este de Libia mantiene un férreo
control sobre la ayuda tras las
inundaciones el desastre que asoló derna
el 11 de septiembre ha atraído de nuevo
la atención internacional sobre haftar y
su llamado ejército nacional libio una
coalición militar que controla con mano
de hier la amistad oriental de la
dividida nación norteafricana hoy los
territorios controlados por este señor
de la guerra funcionan como auténticas
dictaduras militares nada absolutamente
nada escapa su control quizás por eso
gobiernos como el de meloni en Italia
Ven a este señor de la guerra como
alguien capaz de estabilizar los asuntos
migratorios en el Mediterráneo pese a lo
cual se le considera un tipo bastante
distante de occidente Y sabéis qué justo
aquí entra también Moscú Sí sí me habéis
escuchado bien el kremlin sigue muy pero
que muy de cerca la situación Libia por
una razón muy concreta el petróleo yo
sobre todo el
gas Libia amigos no solo tiene crudo
también tiene gas de hecho está entre
las 20 mayores reservas de gas natural
de todo el mundo sin embargo las
exportaciones de gas no han podido
recuperarse ni siquiera un 50% de los
niveles previos al derrocamiento de
gadafi por eso una nueva alia estable y
aliada Bruselas representaría un nuevo
socio energético que ayudaría a
satisfacer la demanda Europea de gas
algo que por supuesto no le interesa
nada de nada a la Rusia de Vladimir
Putin Y esto es exactamente lo que que
empuja a Rusia a respaldar a haftar
mientras que Estados Unidos y otros
varios países europeos sostienen
mediante la ONU el apoyo al gobierno del
acuerdo nacional y su eterna búsqueda de
elecciones el hombre fuerte del este de
Libia haftar se reúne con Putin en Moscú
Eso sí ya sabéis que la política es
política así que ya se están produciendo
contactos entre Washington y haftar para
no llevarse ningún mal susto en el corto
plazo y de hecho en el pasado el propio
Khalifa haftar trabajó con la mismísima
cía hasta el punto de llegar a obtener
la ciudadanía norteamericana ojo con
Cómo son las cosas pues Pues bien El
caso es que ahora este viejo señor de la
guerra parece que podría estar diciendo
que bueno que podría transigir con las
elecciones siempre y cuando eso sí se
asegure que uno de sus hijos pueda
postularse la política familiar un
clásico queridos amigos amigas los
últimos 12 años han sido muy pero que
muy duros para los libios De toda
aquella Primavera árabe llena de
idealismo democrático hoy no queda
absolutamente nada el fracaso del diseño
de la transición y el creciente papel de
un Caudillo militar que promete orden a
cambio de libertad no hura el mejor de
Los Horizontes para este país en visual
politic estaremos atentos pero por ahora
el turno es para ti piensas que acaso el
remedio pudo ser peor que la enfermedad
para los libios Crees que con gadfi les
hubiera ido mejor Qué futuro ves para
este país déjanos tu respuesta como
siempre en los comentarios y ahora si
este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
No olvides darle al botón de like y
suscribirte a visual politic si es que
aún no lo has hecho una vez más Muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo y hasta
la
[Música]
próxima